qu'olivier python français installé aux
états unis avocat au barreau de
washington bonsoir olivier python merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
vous êtes donc on vient de le dire basé
à washington
première question à ce que le calme est
revenu sur place largement c'est à dire
qu'il ya encore des manifestations
durant la journée mais elles sont
extrêmement pacifique
elles sont très calmes et en revanche
l'ensemble découvre fonds était a été
levée en particulier sur la côte est a
par new york et philadelphie qui avait
encore un couvre-feu jusqu'à dimanche le
couvre-feu a été levé
preuve que la situation a quand même
tendance à se calmer ce qui est une très
bonne chose
reste maintenant le message qui est
véhiculée par les pacifistes par l'émail
pardon par les manifestants pacifiques
qui porte
on l a vu bien au-delà des frontières
américaines et qui ont autant d'impact
que je dirais même davantage d'impact
que les émeutes qui ont été relativement
mal perçue par une partie de l'opinion
publique américaine
donc c'est helmut ont tendance à voir
totalement disparu alors il ya un fait
important évidemment c'est la
comparution de ce policier un derek
chauvin pour la première fois
aujourd'hui devant la justice ça va être
important ce qui va ressortir du procès
l'on imagine que voilà c'est une
décision forcément politique pour les
jeunes absolument qu'ils ellison qui est
le procureur qui a donc diligenté
l'enquêté qui a donc inculpé l'ensemble
de l'équipe des policiers autour de
chauvin effectivement par cette
inculpation a déjà fait vraiment baisser
la tension
deuxièmement maintenant on se trouve
face à un cas de figure qui est un tout
petit peu particulier qui existent
malheureusement depuis très longtemps
aux etats unis c'est à dire qu'il va
falloir démontrer que le policier
effectivement a commis un crime alors ça
paraît évident au vu des images ça
paraît évident au vu de l'opinion de
tout le monde mais
il va falloir le démontrer en droit et
jusqu'à présent et c'est l'un des
problèmes que connaît la société
américaine c'est que les policiers
étaient d'une certaine manière
bénéficier si vous voulez d'une sorte de
je vais pas dire de passe droit mais en
tout cas de relative clémence hui égard
à leur à leurs capacités
donc on va voir la maintenance il avec
la situation telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui par la sphère georges floyd
les choses vont changer
et d'une certaine manière les policiers
américains à incriminer vont se
retrouver dans le droit commun c'est ce
que tout le monde souhaite parce que ce
serait ça la véritable avancée de cette
malheureuse à sion et vous nous parler
du côté intouchable entre guillemets de
ces policiers devant la justice
il ya souvent le poids des syndicats un
policier qui les aident beaucoup sur ce
point quel va être le rôle justement ces
syndicats dans ce procès est ce qu'il
faut un petit peu profil bas une fois
n'est pas coutume alors les policiers et
les syndicats de policiers jusqu'à
présent ne sont pas profil bas ils ont
soutenu la démarche des manifestants il
ya eu une vraie unanimité au sein des
sociétés américaines pour condamner ce
crime et pour estimer qu effectivement
il y avait un problème de violence
intrinsèque de la police je n'ai pas de
racisme gdi de violence la question du
racisme est beaucoup plus compliquée
mais elle et elle est très belle celle
enquête qui déterminera effectivement si
l'acte a été véritablement raciste étant
donné que chauvin a subi 18 blâme il va
falloir que l' enquête détermine si au
cours de ses actions qu'ils ont valu ses
18 blâme il s'est systématiquement mal
comporté avec des afro américains ou
s'il s'est comporté mal avec tout le
monde et dans ce cas là la chose serait
véritablement différente en tout cas en
ce qui concerne la violence
la société américaine de manière
écrasante soit est effectivement un
changement de comportement de la police
avec une modification drastique à la
fois de son comportement dans la rue et
en même temps des peines qui peuvent
être lues être un filles qui peuvent lui
être infligée
dans le cas où elle se retrouve
effectivement confrontés à la situation
qu'on a décrit ya quinze jours avec eux
le malheureux audience sur lui alors à
minnesota à minneapolis a on appris
voilà le taureau par les cornes la
police va être carrément démanteler ce
qu'a annoncé les autorités c'est ce sont
les prémices prémices d'un d'un vrai
changement votre avis vers quoi va-t-on
aller tout le monde est très prudent sur
cette histoire de démantèlement d'abord
joe biden a tout de suite dit que
c'était une décision qui serait prise
localement donc lui ne s'est pas avancé
en demandant le démantèlement
systématique de toutes les polices entre
guillemets à problèmes donc c'est une
décision qui sera une décision locale
puisque comme vous le savez la police
elle elle émarge en fait auprès des
municipalités des collectivités locales
sauf pour le cas du fbi enquêtent un
quart et un petit peu a pas donc ça
c'est le premier point
deuxième point si vous voulez dans cette
dans cette affaire la véritable le
véritable problème c'est la proximité de
l'élection présidentielle
tout le monde marche sur des oeufs
chacun comprend bien qu'il faut réformer
les méthodes de la police dans la rue
mais personne n'a envie non plus de
laisser le pays totalement sans défense
où l'impératif de sécurité quand même
toujours présent et on l'a vu puisque
donald trump l'a utilisé à plein dans
son discours le one world heures c'est à
dire la loi et l'ordre
c'est dire que les démocrates essaye de
trouver un équilibre qui est difficile à
trouver entre le fait de répondre aux
aspirations des manifestants et en même
temps de ne pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau
du bain et de considérer que la police
sert quand même à quelque chose et
qu'elle n'est pas coupable
hand soit globalement en généralité si
vous voulez merci beaucoup olivier et
python français installé aux états unis
avocat au barreau de washington d'avoir
apporté cette analyse sur la crise en ce
moment aux états unis